don't breathe comes from the creative
team behind the most recent Evil Dead
remake and stars Jane levy once again as
this lead character that's breaking into
the house of a blind man her and her two
friends have done small robbery jobs on
the side and when they hear that this
older blind man just may have a large
inheritance in that house somewhere they
think well this is going to be easy
little did they know this guy is not
going to give that money up easy and we
have a 90 minute
suspenseful edge-of-your-seat thrill
ride that I loved watching to say this
movie is tense is an understatement
the sound design the editing the
performances the directing the musical
score all of these things come together
to make a absolute white-knuckled
experience I often found myself holding
my breath throughout the runtime of this
movie just like the main characters
would do has this man played excellently
by Stephen Lang is walking through his
hallways trying to find these kids
figure out where they are a lot of the
suspense generated in these scenes
reminded me of those sequences in the
game until dawn or to be one of those
things behind you and it says don't move
and you're supposed to hold the
controller without moving it and if you
move the controller and the motion
sensor thing goes off the things find
you a lot of this movie felt like that
the concept behind this movie is genius
it's such a great idea they get every
ounce of suspense out of this concept
and they did an excellent job with it
her friend in this movie played by Dylan
Manette who was in prisoners and
goosebumps really gets a lot more to do
in this movie than he did in those films
he gets to go to different places here
dramatically I loved seeing that this
movie is squirm in your pants I mean
you're just sitting there everything
about this movie just makes you want to
just curl into a little ball especially
towards the ending which you know I
won't spoil but it just it just makes
you want to sit there in the fetal
position like mama I was so happy to see
all of the various things that I've
complained about in horror movies lately
avoided the jump scares that are in this
film are true they're not false scares
that are just there like somebody
touches somebody's shoulder or some bird
friggin flies on a window or some
bullshit all the scares in this movie
are
effective and they're there to build and
build and heap that suspense intention
upon you and as you learn more about the
man they're trying to rob you begin to
get even more afraid because this guy is
nowhere near as defenseless as they
thought he was and so that added with
the excellent direction and OnPoint
sound design made this an extremely
exciting movie to watch I barely had a
single issue with this movie until the
ending I won't ruin it for you but
there's a part where it cuts to black
and I said that's perfect oh my gosh I
love it and then it fades back in and
there's like three more minutes and
these last three minutes felt like the
alternate ending you might find on the
blu-ray special features you watch it
and go man I'm glad they didn't put that
in except they put it in it really
serves no purpose to the movie it does
nothing for the characters it's just
sort of like hey here's some info for
you it just didn't do anything for the
film or the characters it was
unnecessary to me and I felt this
should've just ended when it cut to
black also there's something as I
watched this movie that began to nag at
me there are an absurd amount of
similarities to panic room David
Fincher's thriller about a home invasion
as well a couple of them are just visual
things like the lead character looking
almost exactly like Jodie Foster does in
that movie there's also a livewire
unpredictable Punk light character who's
in this film who is exactly like Jared
Leto's character in panic room not just
by appearance but the way he acts it's
almost like it follows the same basic
structure of panic room and I was just
kind of thinking maybe it was me until
the end credits of the film are almost
exactly like the opening credits of
panic room showing titles attached to
architecture just like in panic room
those awesome opening titles are sort of
recreated in the ending titles of this
film also when they first break into the
house there's a long unbroken take
panning through the floors through the
wall showing us everything in the house
just like in panic room a lot of the
same story beats happen a lot of very
similar moments happen and I'm not sure
if anyone's picked up on this yet but it
does pay a little too much homage to
panic room and if they weren't going for
it it's an amazing coincidence because
there's a lot of similarities besides
those two things I
don't breathe is a really fun thriller
I'm looking forward to seeing it again
and I'm gonna give it an a-minus guys if
you're a fan of scary movies like I am
but good ones check this one out in
theaters it's worth your time also stay
tuned this Sunday because I'm doing a
video that I'm super excited about I
stumbled across an older movie that's
about 11 years old called stay it stars
Ewan McGregor Ryan Gosling and Naomi
Watts it was directed by Marc Forster it
got very bad reviews and was received
very poorly but I saw something in this
movie it touched me it affected me it
made me think and I want to do an
in-depth analysis of stay it's going to
be up this Sunday
I just delved super deep into it I got
like zodiac Jake Gyllenhaal obsessed
with it it was a lot of fun I'm excited
to share that video with you guys thank
you so much as always for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes